they were warning me be careful this is
too big for you
rumors related to something called a
Super League project that would flip the
power structures of the world's most
popular sport I'm the president of the
most powerful Sports organization in the
world
the community community
quasi-religion but we go to the stadium
rather than the church
but this vast inequality has been
growing for 10 years the rich getting
richer running away from the rest
leaving them with crumbs
the owners used to be local to succeed
now you have to be owned by a small
country
it's meant more problems Europe's
leading football clubs have joined
together to form a breakaway Super
League
could look for better Solutions
something which is well done can be done
better
the younger generation they want to see
the big matches and they want to see the
drama it was obviously blind because he
was my friend I realized that it's a
betrayal the most powerful clubs wanted
to build a future football that they
wholly owned and wholly control
eliminating hundreds of competing teams
just with the stroke of a pen if this
super league would happen the
development of football would stop I am
in love with the games with the passion
of the games I am in love with winning
the games but I am not in love with the
governance in countries big politics big
business this for it's been hydrant
now the war for football has started
foreign
[Music]